yesterday was legal guardian of
unspecified gender day mother's day we
are sensitive here at the ben shapiro
show and we don't want to offend gay
couples or non cisgender couples or
mothers who are men or or i don't know
other other Mowgli's family i don't we
don't want it we don't want to offend
anyone so it was legal guardian
unspecified gendered a second legal
guardian one specified gender day will
be happening in about a month here I
think it's like June 18 the second legal
guardian or legal guardian of
unspecified gender Dec is June 18th but
to celebrate Mother's Day there Cecile
Richards came out of the woodwork Cecile
Richards is of course the head of
Planned Parenthood and she's also a
crazy pro-abortion fanatic so here is
what she tweeted with no sense of
iearning quote nothing says I love you
mom like standing up for the right of
mothers everywhere to get the care they
need Cecile Richards is the head of an
abortion mill on Mother's Day Mother's
Day might be a good time for Cecile
Richards to shut up like don't remind
people of the killing of the babies on
Mother's Day like it's just a bad look
so as I tweeted back at her nothing says
I love you mom with a child you didn't
abort right because the kid can actually
say I love you it is amazing there there
a couple tweets yesterday but I tweeted
about this in a little bit yesterday I
said happy Mother's Day to my wife a
victim of the patriarchy in wonderful
mothers for our two children there are
women who are tweeting out yesterday the
Mother's Day is just terrible because it
makes women into breeders and makes them
into baby machines sorry to break this
to you ladies but part of your biology
is being a baby machine like I'm sorry
sorry to break it to you like there are
other wonderful things that women do but
you have an amazing superpower called
being able to have another child come
out of you which is an unbelievable
thing then this sort of attempt by the
left to turn that into the least of the
things that women do know it's the most
of the things that women do because
humanity disappears if you don't do it
okay like of all the things that human
beings do on the planet bearing and
rearing children is the most important
thing and it's odd to me this is even
mildly controversial like my wife is a
doctor she has one of the most important
jobs you can have she helps save
people's lives every day or if his
patients every day she talks to she
helps she tries to save their lives
tries to make their lives better and you
ask her what is the most important thing
that she does and she says have our kids
and take care of them right and that's
that's not because she's a big
the patriarchy it's because she actually
cares about the next generation she
cares about our children the attempts to
mean what motherhood is by the left is
really one of the most disgusting things
that the left does and the fact that
they've turned women into this attempt
to say that we need what we really need
is we need paid child care so the
mothers can spend more time at work I
don't want a mother who doesn't want to
to spend more time at work something
that the mom wants to spend time at work
that's one thing but then you make
arrangements with your husband like my
wife works longer hours than I do at
this point I spend more time with our
kids right now than she does when she's
done with her residency presumably she
will work part time and then she will
spend more time with the kids than I do
but that shifts over time but that's a
different thing that's because we have a
great marriage we work that out between
ourselves but the idea from the left
that you're actually a bad person you're
doing bad things and you spend more time
on your kids there's a tweet from from
Vox yesterday that said something to the
effect of your mom spends now your mom
spent and wasted 90 minutes a day on you
when you were growing up say thank you
wasted wasted ninety minutes a day I
would I would venture to say that most
mothers feel they wasted much more time
at work than they wasted at home with
their kids I mean the name that name the
mother you know not to get dark hair but
name the name the person the the father
or the mother who on their deathbed
thinks back to his god I really wish
that I had spent more time looking at
those accounts receivable no one does
that but every person says on their
deathbed I wish I had more time to spend
with my kids so this idea that we have
to defend Amin Parenthood in order to
establish quality is just stupidity